me
[音楽]
こんにちは秦と言います
僕は36歳写真家をしています
写真家というのはたくさんの人と出会いいろんな場所に行きます
僕にとってカメラというのは人や場所とつなげてくれるものです
写真家というのは件分の広がるとても楽しい仕事です
僕は東京の郊外で妻と3歳の息子と暮らしています
生まれたばかりの頃は何もできなかった息子が今では自分で歩いて自分で食事をして
くれます
泣くことでしか意思を伝えられなかったのが今では言葉で伝えてくれます
育児というのは大変なこともありますが
子供の成長と共に日々楽になっていることを感じます
楽しい仕事をして家族や友人に恵まれ
ストレスとは無縁の不自由の無い幸せな生活を送っています
僕は一見すると健康そうに見えますが血液がんの患者です
現代の医療では治すことができない病気にかかっています
今こうして立って話すことができますが何
体を起こすことも
痛みや苦しさで会話をすることもできなくなるでしょう
もしくは体調が急変して1ヶ月後にはもう死んでいるかもしれません
人間は誰でもいつか必ず死にます
これは仕方がないことです
しかし苦しんで死ぬということが僕には耐えることができません
苦しさというのは進退的なことだけではありません
好きなことができなくなり嫌なことを押し付けられ自由を奪われるという苦しさが僕に
は耐えられません
自由というのは人間の尊厳でありアイデンティティの基礎になります
人間は生きているから素晴らしいのではなく自由であるから素晴らしいんです
この自由が病気になると奪われようとします
しかし病気が自由を奪うわけではありません
では誰が病人から自由を奪ってしまうのでしょうか
それは病人の周りにいる家族によって自由が奪われてしまうんです
家族というのは1分1秒でも長く生きてほしい
そうお願います
一見するととても聞こえが良い言葉ですが少し見方を変えると自分の家族が死んで
しまうことの悲しみの先送りでしかありません
自分が悲しみたくないから自分が心配をしたくないから自分が安心をするために病人の
自由を奪ってしまうんです
ゆっくりしていなさいと病人をベッドに寝かせて本人の望まない治療や延命措置を施し
てしまうこともあります
本人の意思に関係なく家族の判断によって回復の見込みがないのに
機械によって強制的にイかす延命措置を僕は正しいとは思いません
自由を奪うということは人間の尊厳を奪う行為です
医者は患者の希望ではなく家族の希望を優先します
患者が延命措置を拒否していても家族が延命措置を求めれば医者は延命措置を施します
運転免許証の裏にある臓器提供意思カード
あれに本人が提供する医師のサインをしていても家族が反対をすれば臓器提供はされ
ません
日本には病人の石を保証する方法が一切ありません
僕たちの命は僕たちが決めるのではなく悲しみたくないという家族によって決定され
ます
僕の妻は僕の意思を尊重すると思います
しかし僕の親族や妻の親族が妻にプレッシャーを与えます
そのプレッシャーに砂が負けてしまう可能性だってあります
日本の移動でベルというのは世界的に見てとても高い水準を保っています
しかしそれは助けることができる命に限った話です
助けることができない後に対して日本の医療というのはとても低いと言わざるを得ませ
ん
僕は自分の尊厳を守るために安楽死をすることを検討しています
安楽死というのは日本では違法行為のため海外に行ってやることになります
しかしこれはそう簡単な話ではありません
体調が急変したりタイミングが一つでもずれれば海外に行って安楽死ということはでき
ないでしょう
僕は実際に安楽死をするための会員登録を済ませていますが実際に安楽死ができる可能
性というのはとても低いと考えています
おそらくできないでしょう
日本人が海外で安楽死をするというのはとてもハードルが高いことです
日本国内でも安楽死ができるように法律を変える必要があると僕は考えています
自分の命を自然な寿命で全うしたいという人
延命措置をしてでも行きたいという人
これ以上苦しみたくないから安楽死をしたいという人
それぞれの価値観に対応していくには選択肢の幅を広げるしかありません
そしてその選択肢を家族ではなく患者本人が選ぶ必要があります
家族であろうと誰であろうと人の価値観を指定してはいけないのです
人の価値観を否定して自分の価値観を押し付けることが自由を奪う第一歩です
すべては価値観の私邸から始まります
安楽死の話をすると多くの人が最後の死に方だけを注目します
しかし本当に大切なことは死に方ではなく生き方です
好きなことをして自由に生きるというのが僕にとっては大切な生き方です
安楽死を選択することによって最後に苦しまなくていいという安心感が
行きやすさを後押ししてくれます
いつでも楽に死ぬことができるそう考えることによってギリギリまで最後まで頑張って
生きようという気持ちになります
諦めるんじゃないがんばれ
こういった言葉は健康な方からたくさん言われてきました
これらの言葉は助からない患者にとって得になる言葉です
僕は自分の人生を諦めているわけでもなく死にたいわけでもなくただ最後まで楽しく
生きたいだけです
僕は自分の死と向き合うことで生きることとは何だろうということもよく考えるように
なりました
人はいつか死んでしまうのにどうして生まれて生きるんでしょうか
僕がたどり着いた答えは人は人それぞれの幸せを享受するために生きているということ
です
僕の幸せと誰かの幸せは違います
自分の幸せを見つけてそれを享受することが生きる理由だと僕は考えています
子供というのは自ら進んで嫌なことはしません
自ら進んでやることは楽しいことばかりです
子供の好きなことを自由にやらせていれば子供はずっと笑顔です
本当は誰もが子どもの時に感じていたことを大人になる途中で忘れてしまったのかも
しれません
幸せを享受するというとても簡単な答えを僕は大きな病気をするまで気づけていません
でした
そして健康な時に持っていたよくの意味のなさにも気づきます
たとえばお金や名誉女性にモテたい
いわゆる男性が想像しがちなよくの意味のなさにも気づきます
これらはあのように一緒に守っているわけではないので死ぬ人間にとっては必要がない
ものです
病気になった今僕は自分の欲や幸せではなく誰かの幸せを願うようになりました
須磨や息子の幸せや友人たちの幸せを心から願っています
付き合った時間の長さではなく付き合った時間の質が大切になり
たった数時間しか会わなかった人の幸せを願うようになりました
もしかしたら本当の幸せというのは誰かの幸せを願えることなのかもしれません
そして誰かの幸せを願うにはまず自分が幸せてなければ心からは願いないでしょう
そして自分が幸せになるには自由が保障されていなければなりません
生きることや幸せについて皆さんもぜひ考えてみてください
自分や家族が大きな病気になった時に必ず役に立ちます
[拍手]